Istanbul the Gateway to the Orient here
at the Bosphorus is where Asia and
Europe meet Istanbul is also where
Germany and Turkey meet at the first
Turkish German University situated in a
suburb north of the city about 120
students began a bachelor's program in
mid-september currently the university
offers BA programs in law business and
mechatronics more affirmed budget is in
the mechatronics program
he says Germany has a lot to offer in
the engineering sciences high-qualified
engineer unit another language which is
German I think because German is very in
front of the other camp other countries
like most of the incoming students
marathon doesn't speak much German he
and his fellow students will spend a
year learning the language then they'll
start on their course of studies the
primary language of instruction will be
German this group of students have
already started on their regular course
of study about 20 incoming students grew
up in Germany or attended German
speaking high schools here in Turkey
they also have specific reasons for
wanting to study here placed in thought
you stun that [ __ ] sir I appreciate
German academic standards in Germany
everything has a system and everything
operates according to this system and
its rules we tend not to have that here
in Turkey I wanted to live in a
different country my own country that is
the country of my heritage and I think
my chances of advancement are much
better here nine Turkish and nine German
professors are teaching at the new
University the German faculty commute
between Istanbul and their University
back at home the German academic
exchange service is bearing the costs
the buildings where classes are being
held at just temporary construction on
the new university buildings will begin
next year the administration hopes
they'll be done by 2017 about 35 million
euros have already been invested in the
project most of it from Turkey Germany
plans to contribute about 4 million
euros per year the Turkish embassy in
Berlin says the new university is long
overdue
after all Germany is one of turkey's
most important international partners
yeah I'm sure the American university
has been in Turkey for more than a
hundred years now the French for nearly
50 there's also been a German High
School in Turkey for more than 100 years
but there hasn't been a university which
is hard to understand so I'm especially
pleased that it's finally working out
vitas ooh smooth the former president of
the German parliament and member of the
Christian Democratic Party played an
important role in making that happen
today she heads an important consortium
at the Turkish German University it took
as long as it did because we kept having
these political moments when turkey said
oh so you don't really want us in the EU
it will not lead to delays Germany hopes
the university will help promote the
development of civil society in Turkey
this has become all the more urgent
since the events at gezi Park in June
when police responded harshly to the
demonstrations at Taksim Square the
protests are also widely talked about at
the University the things happen in
Taksim it's just it just bothered me
because it wasn't the thing the thing we
should do I am kind of welcome we don't
have full democracy that's 100 percent
functional but now we've seen people
take to the streets to make their
opinions heard it's given us a push that
we really needed
the university administration doesn't
think there will be any conflict between
the German and Turkish faculty when it
comes to the curriculum not even when it
comes to questions of politics and
democracy bonds in the political
sciences why shouldn't we discuss a
variety of opinions and analyze them to
come up with the right conclusions isn't
to go out and start holding forth like
missionaries our job is first to listen
to the discussions that are happening in
Turkey and then ask questions about
what's happening here the joint
University is already an important
milestone in German Turkish relations
and students like Marathon badger also
hope it will be a springboard to a
successful career whether that's here in
Turkey
or back in Germany